le match qui devait aborder la
problématique et militant qu'ailleurs
l'étudiant de l'amont mais où justement
y prenons en considération parce qu'il y
aura tous et nous donc assassiné nous
que les gars étaient la novaya j quoi de
mieux que rassemblement pour soutenir
toi camarade amenés à répondre devant la
justice suite aux mouvements de
protestation devant un centre commercial
e robert le 23 novembre dernier
hier soir militants sympathisants et
autres ont répondu à l'appel
ils dénoncent ce qu'ils jugent
inacceptables les yuccas attaqué sept
militants c'est pas lisse et plat est
touché mais c'est tout pète matnik ya eu
l'attaqué et c'est tout plat unique qui
pour répondre c'est andy dans l'esprit
talla que en voyage organisations
syndicales politiques associations et
puis de matinée qu'au sien il semblait
évident en comité caisse janvier 2020
ces militants trouve dommage que les
politiques au pouvoir n'est pas pris à
bras le corps ce problème qui amènent
leurs camarades devant la justice car
montrez nous où verra sûrement que
quelques paniers à de nous et au
contraire parce que nous gagnons avec
une idée des bagues et pour mettre en
place quand la loi pollueur-payeur même
sa yo pa sayo passe à exiger que yom et
eloi salle en place donc nous a bien
constaté qu'il y aura fait gemalto il y
aura moteab à new york- you are go la
ffn fédération socialiste de la
martinique déplorent cette façon de
procéder pour condamner la justice en
vue de faire des exemples mais je crois
que ce gouvernement a montré également
sa façon de vrais et la violence avec
laquelle elles réprimaient les
mouvements sociaux
donc c'est dans la continuité des
méthodes de la république en marché de
ce gouvernement
rendez vous le 13 janvier à 14 heures au
tribunal correctionnel de fort de france
concernant les sept militants
interpellés chez eux
le 28 novembre dernier